has it ever occurred to you as you walk
down the street just how much data is
Flowing beneath your feet a wealth of
information on our health and our
well-being is running through our City
sewers and we're all contributing to it
every single time we use the
toilet think about it everybody pees and
poops and we know that urine and stool
contain a rich source of information on
our health and our wellbeing our doctors
look at it all the time to analyze for a
variety of things now every time you
flush you're sending this valuable
information down into our sewers where
it's mixing with waste from hundreds of
thousands of other people once collected
it looks something like this this tiny
sample comes from a wastewater treatment
plant that represents more than 1
million people and from it we can detect
all sorts of things about that community
the Infectious Disease viruses that are
circulating in our bodies chemical
markers for the drugs that are most
commonly consumed and we can analyze for
all the bacteria that live in our
Collective
microbiomes Now if this sounds too close
for comfort just consider all the
personalized data that you're parting
with every day when you use gadgets like
your smartphone or your Smartwatch
what's amazing about sewage is that it's
naturally aggregated and anonymized
once flushed your waist is mixing with
that of thousands and thousands of
people so there's actually no way to tie
any information from here back to a
specific person put differently it's the
perfect data
dump the thoughtful collection and
Analysis of sewage has the potential to
radically improve health outcomes in
cities around the world and it's a
growing field called Wastewater
epidemiology and waste water
epidemiology is but one example of all
the big data that we're generating in
our cities
today consider all the data that you
generate with every phone call package
delivered mild driven it's data from
camera sensors drones air quality water
quality monitoring and the vast amounts
of information generated by our
Healthcare and our Educational
Systems all of this information these
digital breadcrumbs tell us unique
stories about our cities and the way
that we live our lives the thoughtful
collection and Analysis of this
information has the power to inform
realtime improvements to things like
social policy Environmental Management
Health Equity and more as an architect I
believe that we need to harness the
hundreds of millions of terabytes of
data that we're generating in our cities
each and every day and this is important
now more than ever because For the First
Time in human history more than half of
all people live in cities by 2050 this
number will grow to nearly 7 in 10
people now just think about what that
means for a second it means our biggest
crises from climate change to pandemics
to Growing inequality are going to hit
cities first and
hardest but the era of Big Data offers
an opportunity for new and Creative
Solutions to tackle these
problems so let's dive into the
opportunity presented by Wastewater
epidemiology some of you may have heard
of it as it gained a lot of popularity
and attention during the covid-19
pandemic in 2020 research groups from
around the world began detecting SARS
CO2 RNA the virus that causes covid-19
in sewage samples I was on one of those
teams we and others showed that you can
actually use sewage as an accurate
representation of covid activity in our
communities let me show you what I mean
here we're looking at a time series over
the course of the pandemic so from March
2020 through just last week the Blue
Line represents covid virus
concentrations in sewage samples from
across the United States in yellow we
see covid clinical case data for the
first two years of the pandemic case
data was very reliable people were
getting PCR tested all the time during
those two years the two data sets
tracked very well that was great it
meant that sewage was also reliable and
an accurate representation of disease
burden however over the past year and a
half to two years we've seen a
Divergence in those data sets people
just aren't getting covid tested nearly
as often sewage on the other hand
doesn't require us to Access Healthcare
Services we're all represented just by
peeing and pooping throughout the
pandemic we and others also showed that
sewage is prediced
and a leading indicator of new covid
clinical cases this is because
infectious disease viruses incubate in
our bodies before we develop symptoms or
go get tested meanwhile we've been
excreting the virus for days during
covid it was shown that sewage was
anywhere between 1 to 3 weeks leading
indicator for clinical
cases now I'm going to show you an
example of one time that this led to a
big community acting decision here we're
looking at data from the Boston area
during the Omicron wave in December 2021
towards the end of the month covid cases
began to Skyrocket across the country
and didn't slow until the end of January
Boston Children's Hospital though was
ready they had been looking at Boston
area sewage and saw the sewage levels go
up weeks earlier so they proactively
postponed all non-emergency medical
procedures they wanted to free up
resources so that they could adequately
respond to the incoming wave of
hospitalizations now Wastewater
epidemiology has been used to tackle
other pressing health issues as well
before the pandemic the biggest Public
Health crisis in the United States was
our growing drug
epidemic drug overdoses were growing
year-over-year and had become the
leading cause of accidental death for
Americans under the age of 50 in 20 8 a
small town in North Carolina had seen
overdoses go up and they wanted better
information better data to know what to
do about it what was driving this trend
and how to respond so we turned to the
sewers and together with the mayor's
office we began to analyze sewage
samples from several sites across the
city and were able to show that
prescription opioids were the drug most
commonly consumed not injectable
opioids equipped with with this data the
city diverted resources from needle
exchange sites and put that money into
medication takeback programs instead
they advertised and held dozens of town
halls where they talked about the
adverse effects of prescription
painkillers that year the city saw a 40%
reduction in overdoses and for the first
time they had engage their community in
a dialogue around drugs addiction and
overdose now imagine if every city
around the world had access to this sort
of information before the pandemic
Wastewater epidemiology was a tiny field
with no more than a dozen experts
worldwide today 72 countries have used
Wastewater monitoring to understand
covid-19 and it's time that we leverage
these Investments to monitor for all
sorts of other things as well imagine
knowing when influenza and RSV are going
to going to Peak every year so that our
hospitals can prepare imagine mapping
nutrition in our cities so that we can
identify food deserts and understand
social determinants of Health imagine
identifying super bugs and antibiotic
resistant genes as they emerge in our
communities imagine preventing the next
pandemic before it
happens in the way that Cher prompted
London to build modern-day sewer systems
and poor health in the tenements of New
York City were one of the catalysts
behind the building of Central Park this
is how our cities can learn from
covid-19 and this is precisely how we
can foster a new intelligent kind of
urbanization for years now scientists
policy makers Architects and urban
planners have been harnessing the power
of technology and big data to Future
proof our
cities over the last decade Chief Tech
technology officers have been appointed
in cities around the
world roles once reserved for the
boardrooms and hallways of Silicon
Valley are now finally open in City
Hall so next time you swipe your credit
card take a ride in a taxi or tap your
Metro card just consider how you're
contributing to your city's ever growing
digital
infrastructure and next time you use the
toilet just remember you're doing your
civic
duty thank
you